covid rates are up sharply once again
and nowhere are they higher than Dundee
the city is Scotland's hot spot a nation
where one in 100 people has the virus
according to new data from the office
for National statistics we've already
had a delay in the easing of
restrictions in Scotland in recent
months and in fact for that's been local
in Glasgow and then National applied to
other areas so the next big date for us
of course is also July the 19th to level
zero which still some restrictions
before fewer and the Scottish government
is not ruling anything out
the Delta variant is driving the rise
but it's the easing of restrictions that
letting it loose and it's the same
across the UK
let's look at the latest numbers the r
number a measure of how fast the virus
is spreading is now between 1.2 and 1.5
up slightly from last week a new ons
figures show what that means for cases
more than 400 000 people are estimated
have been infected in the week up to
July the 3rd that's a rise of 56 on the
previous week and just look at how the
third wave has picked up speed at the
start of June the weekly Rising cases
was just seven percent
Scotland's High rate of 1 in 100 people
being infected was followed by England
where one in 160 had the virus in
Northern Ireland it was one in 300 and
in Wales just one in 340. within England
the Northeast is now the hot spot with
one in 69 people infected overtaking the
Northwest elsewhere infection rates are
rising much more slowly with the lowest
rates in the east of England with around
1 in 300 infected
Hospital admissions and deaths aren't
Rising as fast in this way thanks to the
vaccine but new data from public health
England is concerning it looked at 257
people known to have died with a Delta
variant 92 were unvaccinated but 118 had
had both doses that's because the
vaccine is good but not perfect the
overwhelming majority of deaths were
people aged 50 or older reflecting the
strong age-related risk of covid it's
what you would expect but it shows that
even if you've had your Jabs you're
still at small risk and deaths are
likely to rise as cases Surge from the
rapid rollback of lockdown